have you ever thought of living
somewhere else is this pandemic made you
want to live somewhere else yeah
this pandemic hasn't done it but really
a lot of you just before life experience
yeah really
but it's hard being in show business to
live somewhere else now it's a little
easier with what we do but
it's tough man i i battle back and forth
like me and my girl
in two weeks go to austin to look at
house she's never been there we go look
because we think about moving there
and then it's like i'm talking to theo
and brian i'll see there's a million
moving parts for me to go there because
it's not like
i just have one show if it's just
showtime just blow the bell i could get
up and go yeah
food trucks from there we can fly
fighters out there well chin and cat
will figure it out
but it's like you know i have king in
the sting i got blood i got fire in the
kid so there's all this moving pieces
and everyone's down but then when you
look at the logistics of it
it just it just it gets hairy man here's
here and then
my thing is it's like i don't mean to
rep you i'm like is it because
right now it's just like la's on fire
like
la's so extreme yeah but when it's not
on fire it's amazing here
in new york's extreme when it's not on
fire it's amazing the the real
problem with los angeles not southern
california
la the real downside to it is that
the perception is absolutely
not the reality and that you get turned
off
all of us do we get turned off by the
superficial nature of the entertainment
industry
and everyone's just worried about image
and not they're not real
substantial people and there's no
culture and the traffic and the
overpopulation and all this
and that is undoubtedly
real and there are definitely people i
mean the entertainment industry kind of
lives and breathes here
that are just consumed with the industry
they don't really give a [ __ ] about
actual human interaction and they don't
care about people's feelings
but in the 11 million
or so people that live in l.a county
like like .08 percent work in the
[ __ ] entertainment industry and i
always use the laker game as an example
the first three rows of it at a laker
game they are those douchebags they are
those guys with the sunglasses on
indoors with a chick that's like 45
years younger than them and they're
they but the reality is is there's 18
other seats in the lego game and it's
all it's a [ __ ] mechanic
and that's it and and truck drivers and
cops and [ __ ] drivers normal people
and the image that is given is that
all of los angeles is these first three
dummy dudes and by the way
99 of those [ __ ] bags aren't from la
no you know everyone every goddamn guy i
talk to in the internet entertainment
industry is like ah
pizza is better in new york where i'm
from oh in boston you go you can get
you can get yourself a nice [ __ ] hero
sandwich i'm like oh really
that's all you're gonna do is i just
like i'm not mo i'm the worst
i'd be the worst superhero ever because
i'm the least ambitious person
if i had [ __ ] you mind if i was jeff
bezos all i do
is buy a gigantic office building in la
and just plaster it with nothing but
dodger [ __ ]
and like like like like mr cartoon
graffiti and everything
just like make it la centric every
[ __ ] [ __ ] who gets off a [ __ ]
plane from
pittsburgh and and florida all over the
country and the first thing they do is
talk about how much
better their hometown is that's all la i
know in reality though
you're you're this much the rest of the
city has this unbelievable vibrant
culture
that is not really looked at it's just
like like 10 years ago
everyone in the world looked at new
jersey as being the dudes on jersey
shore
yeah like that or sopranos like yeah
they they get a bad rap
have you been to jersey you live ninja
jerseys i don't know that
jersey is one of the most jersey is one
of the most educated places in this
country
it's filled with some of the most nice
thoughtful people in the world and yeah
sure there's a bunch of guidos and a
bunch of you know
you know like absolute but again that's
the point 01
the majority of the yeah some of the
best people i know brian daley like
a ton of people live in jersey and uh
you know i
my wife gets really concerned about like
what are we going to do we can't live in
l.a
because i fill in the blank yeah kids
get sticky
don't and you're in venice right yeah
now don't get me wrong venice is
dangerous but i always go like look
there's human shields
fall for the trap don't take the bait
because
you as an actress are surrounded by
this segment of it that
gives it the bad rap you know these
people that are and and i've watched my
wife who's successful
in acting i've watched her get [ __ ]
decimated by people who are just so
callous
there's far too many people in politics
and in show business
that lose sight of just basic courtesy
and they are not
nice well that's everything mike sports
i mean go have a talk with the
you know i don't know now the
matchmakers they're a lot better but go
have a talk with dana white man or
anyone who runs a business or have these
they have these decisions to make they
just don't
they just it's almost like they don't
view human life the same as others you
know because i think
they're just like on to the next i don't
know it's just what's next and they're
like
they have shark eyes it's just all black
like what how the [ __ ] did you get this
way
i've met with agents here it's the same
way it's like
how you wonder though is there value in
it
in a in a job like being a politician
being being
being being a studio exec maybe there's
there's actual benefits to being a
sociopath well there's a reason why
they're like that
it's just a bummer it's heartbreaking
dude go the nfl
even when you get to the nfl man i mean
you know these coaches
it's like what i don't give a [ __ ] dude
catch the ball next and you're like oh
god or a gm or a head coach at the same
time you've got to understand like
that even compared to most people who
make [ __ ] tons of money the pressure and
the amount of money that
other people have writing on you in your
performance i kind of understand where
you
like there's probably isn't any room for
for you know concerns about people's
emotions no guys
the guy or a gal is not holding it up on
the field you're gone i mean you kind of
same in hollywood though if a guy
or gal isn't holding it up or if they're
not right for the part then i can be
like yeah you know this [ __ ] they're
just like
next get the [ __ ] out of here yeah that
i mean and that
look it is a meritocracy in that sense
where you know kind of talent dictates
what i don't like
about especially sports is a little bit
easier because
sports is black and white it doesn't
matter if you're best friends with a
coach or if you're a nice guy or if you
played the political game behind the
scenes
if you don't if your [ __ ] shooting
percentage is 16 you're not gonna make
it in the nba if you
if you hit 183 for three seasons in the
nba major league you're done
acting's all there is like this thing
and i i've talked about it with so many
of my friends with that you know i
i go just keep your chin up because it's
very frustrating
for someone to really to know not to
think
but to know that there's other things at
play that are preventing you from being
as successful as you want to be
besides hard work and drive like when
you were really driven when you're
hard-working when you devote yourself in
every and there's still
other factors that get in the way that's
really really [ __ ] frustrating and i
know life's not fair
but that sucks at least with you could
be a gigantic [ __ ]
but if you're [ __ ] awesome in sports
no one's stopping you no one's going to
prevent you know and like
let's know the extremes i mean well
acting is a little bit like baseball
where you
you're gonna go about three for ten yeah
if you go three for ten you're [ __ ]
killing it yeah you go about one out of
ten
i i also really worry about
how like you know what was really
exciting and what made me fall in love
with movies in particular
was that when i was like first getting
to the age where i could appreciate the
idea of artwork and like cinema and
going in like seeing that their subtext
and that someone put a lot of effort
into making a piece of art to be
observed
i was like 14 15 16. and that was
the mid early to mid 90s and there was
just this explosion
of amazing independent cinema and i'm
starting as like a 12 year old i'm
seeing
reservoir dogs and as i'm graduating
high school i'm watching boogie nights
and stuff and i'm thinking like
oh my god i really appreciate this idea
that people can have
amazing creative feelings and and commit
themselves to it and and present me this
with the way the studios are working now
and now the agencies are getting into
creating content
the utas the wmes now they're like
making their own projects they're just
going to stack the deck with their own
clients and then everything's packaged
and i feel like the guy or gal who just
has a great idea and
a belief in themselves is getting
skinned getting washed away you know
so that that's what really bugs me about
it but
i do i honestly do believe like there's
a
i'm maybe i'm overly optimistic but i
have a real love affair
with the city of los angeles i know
that's why i'm asking because i'm
literally i'm on the fence i go
in a week or two to go look at texas as
i'm getting closer i find myself
just like i do you know we wrote a list
pros and cons and as i'm going through
the con starting to build up
i'm leaving la it mean but my love
affair is real and i do see all the
i always say like new york chicago miami
they are like um an amazing like marvel
comic book movie you know what you're
getting when you go in there and it is
amazing you go and you sit you go to new
york city and you're like
it's gonna be amazing statute of liberty
and i'm going to go see central park and
it's going to be over the top times
square is going to blow me away
and you land and you go there you're
like whoa this is the center of
existence so new york city is amazing
at south beach you're like what the [ __ ]
look at all these beautiful people
la is like a film noir you kind of don't
know you you have this idea of what
you're going to see but you sit down
you're like
was that it yeah you got it kind of flat
but then
upon further inspection you see what
goes on in the shadows and you're like
oh
this city has so much to offer it
doesn't blow you away because you like
you go down to like the
walk of fame or something you know if
you're a tourist place you're going to
walk around you're like what the [ __ ]
and then you go to disneyland you're
like okay i guess but when you if you
don't go to like the graffiti walls in
venice if you don't go see like the low
rider
you know the low riders at on whittaker
boulevard yes like the the real
the vibrant blood of the city it's
amazing it's amazing it's better than
anywhere in the whole world the
the culture the the the modern art and
the and the the street art and the and
the kind of like
the underbelly of los angeles is uh is
beautiful but
it's very hard to see it's not it's not
something that is it doesn't no not
everyone's gonna tell you about it but
and there's there's so many different
spots in california just
fan-fucking-tastic man from venice to
marina santa monica
malibu the palisades it's too far apart
though everything's too far apart in la
that sucks that does so it's far apart
when the world's
back to normal and there's traffic yeah
like right now it's not bad like right
now anywhere you want to go it's like
you want to go downtown it's 18 minutes
you want to go to the valley it's 18
minutes everything's 18 minutes like can
you imagine if it's like this all the
time
i i do have that like a severe passion i
i love
i'm mexican i love to drive i love cars
everything fits i love the dodgers i
love the lakers everything's your
favorite you're the most la guy now i
love in a good way meaning like right
la like not all night not hollywood l.a
but i love a lot of places and i've
thought about like
i'd love to live in like midland texas
i'd love to live in nashville
i'd love to live in in you know outside
of just outside of atlanta i know i'd
love to live in
in you know somewhere in the like i was
thinking of cleveland
i was conceived in cleveland oh yeah my
parents thought that that was where
they're going to live and then
like when my mom was pregnant with me
they my dad got cleveland's dope
washington dc i could live in dc dc dc
is great but dc
almost you deal with the same problem my
my closest buddy lives in dc
he he he complains about the same kind
of problem that you deal with with the
entertainment industry
in um in la is that the the political
system is
it's it's not just something that's
there it it bleeds into the fabric of
everything you do even if you're not in
politics you know so
i i've thought of it but i i just i love
i've never really been to places in
america and i'm
i'm admittedly um pollyannish about this
country i'm i'm
openly like super pro-american i love
this country
and maybe it's because i've had the
chance to go to
really shitty places i don't think
enough people who and i'm not saying
there's not
tremendous flaws in how we do things in
this country i'm not saying that there
aren't things that desperately need to
be changed
no but what i am saying the dick if you
talk [ __ ] about america if you go to
saudi arabia if you've been there if you
go to [ __ ]
uh parts of south america you're like oh
america's so
awesome right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected